hi guys in this video we're going to
talk about kimchi and it's a fermented
vegetable similar sauerkraut Koreans
consume per person about 40 pounds of
kimchi every single year so it's a
combination of cabbage and onion and
garlic and radish chili pepper and
ginger credible combination it's very
spicy the radish is really high in
sulfur so the garlic and the onions
which is really good for the liver to
detox and the kidneys to detox and of
course cabbage as well so it's a great
perm nted food has massive amounts of
vitamin C huge amounts of beta-carotene
and also has vitamin k2 which is
normally seen in grass-fed dairy but
it's also in sauerkraut and kimchi also
minerals calcium iron there's a B
vitamins so we have the nutrients and
the vegetables and then we have the
added benefit of the fermentation so
when you ferment vegetables you get a
lot of friendly microbes friendly
bacteria and lactic acid and that lactic
acid is very good to protect the immune
system to kill up unfriendly microbes to
aid in the assimilation of minerals in
your gut so if you don't have enough
acid in your large bowel you're not
going to simulate as many nutrients so
it also improves bad breath and chronic
halitosis so make sure you start
including more fermented vegetables into
your diet thanks for watching hey you
probably already subscribed but if you
haven't press this little button down
below and I will keep you updated